[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
en el marco del foro económico mundial
estamos con el ministro de hacienda de
Colombia José Antonio Campos ministro
Muchas gracias por atendernos y le
pregunto Bueno cómo ha sido la
participación de Colombia en este foro
bueno ha sido bastante amplia ha estado
el presidente de la república
he estado tres ministros y otros
representantes del gobierno que trabaja
en distintos temas entonces creo que ha
sido latente muy positiva y o sea por lo
que me consta a mí mi participación creo
que ha sido bastante amplia
me acaba de estrenar una reforma
tributaria porque no nos cuenta Cuáles
son los Pilares básicos de esa reforma y
cómo piensan cambiar la economía bueno
esa reforma tiene varios elementos pero
era un una mayor progresividad que
básicamente es eliminar beneficios para
personas naturales de altos ingresos y
un impuesto al patrimonio que Esperamos
que sea permanente un segundo elemento
fue
temporalmente Elevar los impuestos a al
petróleo y al carbón que son los
sectores de exportación con altísimos
precios internacionales para que ellos
contribuyan al corto plazo Eso depende
del precio internacional de cuando los
precios bajen pues la ese elemento de la
tributación va a bajar tercero es un
cambio en en puestos a las empresas
básicamente
beneficios se eliminan pero en
particular yo diría la zona francas
cuando venden al mercado interno porque
digamos una empresa que es una franca
que vende en el mercado interno pagaba
20% una empresa localizada fuera de zona
franca pagada 35 Entonces era una una
competencia injusta digamos entonces ese
elemento y algunos otros beneficios que
se eliminaron hubo un cuarto elemento
fue el régimen simple de tributación que
es para las muy pequeñas empresas que se
mejoró significativamente para bajar los
impuestos y para ver si logramos que
mucho más empresas se incorporen al
régimen tributario si se formalice
tributariamente no un quito fue unos
impuestos a bebidas
azucaradas alimentos
Ultra procesados como de llama y
plásticos de uso y carbono que son
puestos de digamos de carácter
de salud pública y el medio ambiente y
finalmente muchas normas para fortalecer
la capacidad de la de la dirección de
impuestos y avadas nacionales de
limitarla o evitar la la evasión
tributaria Cuáles son los los más
recientes cifras de inversión extranjera
si el año pasado tuvimos más de diez mil
millones de dólares de inversión
extranjera directa y además flujos de
portafolio muchos de los cuales además
se invierten en en títulos de deuda
pública no y creo que fue una una
situación Pues continuando a tendencia
que ha sido muy positiva a lo largo del
tiempo en el caso de la inversión
extranjera directa obviamente todavía
una proporción alta de petróleo y gas
digamos pero también de otros sectores y
debo decir que lo que yo percibo es el
altísimo interés de los extranjeros en
invertir en Colombia no en el caso del
flujo de portafolio incluso fuimos en
contra la tendencia
de salida de capitales de economías
emergentes y Tuvimos una entrada de
capitales Pues que fue casi todos los
meses muy positivo y Y que veamos los
debo decir la los inversionistas
extranjeros por ejemplo compran una
cuarta parte de nuestros títulos deuda
pública en moneda nacional ministro qué
van a hacer para para controlar esa
inflación que sigue tan desenfrenada a
pesar de la constante alza de tasas de
interés bueno el tema más grave de la de
la inflación de la inflación de
alimentos y allá hay digamos dos
factores
uno de los cuales ambos Esperamos que se
reviertan este año el primer elemento es
la inflación internacional que incluso
pues afecta directa o indirectamente la
producción de alimentos por ejemplo la
medida en que hay importación de maíz y
soya para para la alimentación de de
pollos y
y de cerdos pues la carne de pollo de
cerdo y los huevos también aumentan de
precio no Entonces es un elemento que
además se ve muy afectado por la tasa de
cambio que también Tuvo una evaluación
importante el año pasado y lo segundo
Pues fue el tema climatológico la
inundaciones que digamos generar una
reducción de la de la oferta agrícola yo
creo que eso es dos fenómenos que son
muy importantes se van a revertir este
año
ya tenemos menor devaluación de hecho a
una pequeña revaluación los precios
internacionales están bajando y
Esperamos que las condiciones
climatológicas incluso cambien de signo
Ese es como un elemento hay otros
políticas que hemos venido adoptando por
ejemplo
ajustar los precios no con el salario
mínimo sino con la sino con la
infracción Total que es menor Ese fue
otra política que impulsamos hay también
en el caso del sector agrícola subsidio
los fertilizantes que se utilizan para
la producción de Soto de alimentos y el
café que también fue muy afectado por
condiciones climatológicas pero son
algunas medidas puntuales que también se
han tomado para digamos para ayudar Yo
estoy muy bueno perdón quizá la última
es la la decisión de no aumentar los
peajes para que los costos de transporte
no aumente este año claro ministro y
también a nivel internacional se ha
venido hablando en la ocde de un
impuesto a las multinacionales es un
impuesto mínimo ya
con esto Qué opinión de este tema Bueno
Nosotros también introdujimos el puesto
mínimo del 15% en nuestra reforma
tributaria como parte de los compromisos
además con la con la ocde y además
estamos impulsando una cooperación
tributaria latinoamericana que digamos
que una parte implemente mucho mejor las
acuerdos de la doce pero incluso impulse
nuevos acuerdos de la ocd que que
beneficien más los países en desarrollo
por ejemplo una cosa que no
realmente quedó no quedó bien en las el
acuerdo hace dos años Fue la los
impuestos a las multinacionales creo que
busca Es que la multinacionales paguen
justamente lo que corresponde en los
distintos países donde hacen ventas o
donde hacen producción digamos tal como
quedó en la en la norma eso solamente se
muy grande multinacionales muy grandes
por una parte Pero por otra parte
digamos el mecanismo de redistribución
no es totalmente benéfico para los
países en desarrollo Entonces es un tema
que que todavía queda pendiente entonces
nosotros vamos a impulsar un acuerdo
latinoamericano en materia tributaria
digamos que trate complemente esos
acuerdos de la ocd de hace dos años
Gracias ministro
encantado estar con ustedes Gracias por
su sintonía esta y otras entrevistas en
France 24.com